des journalistes amicaux le président
tchèque n'a pas trouvé beaucoup et en
quatre en quoi est ce sont les ennemis
du peuple vous est il encore dans un
rassemblement il ya quelques jours des
attaques surtout adressé aux médias
américains
mais cette fois les correspondants
étrangers sont dans le collimateur dans
une nouvelle directive
le département de la sécurité intérieure
dit vouloir limiter la durée de séjour
des journalistes aux états unis pour
écrit-on réduire la fraude et améliorer
la sécurité nationale un mode panique et
c'est ainsi qu'a réagi le président de
l'association de la presse étrangère
actuellement fixé à 5 ans la limite de
séjour pour les correspondants étrangers
passerait à 240 jours après quoi leur
visa de travail serait renouvelable
moi je vous dirais que j'ai passé cinq
ans aux états unis cinq ans à washington
comme correspondant de radio canada
il commençait à peine à comprendre le
pays après sa 15e débat entre deux tubes
et joe biden maintenant revenu au canada
il insiste sur l'importance du temps
pour bien saisir la réalité de nos
voisins du sud
je vois très mal comment en 240 jours
on peut efficacement de façon
consciencieuse et sérieuse faire son
corps dans son travail de correspondant
le service de l'information de
radio-canada d'ailleurs se dit très
préoccupé par l'intention du
gouvernement américain de réduire la
durée des visas de travail des
journalistes étrangers
les médias étrangers et les ambassades
ont par ailleurs encore quelques jours
jusqu'au 26 octobre pour faire part de
leur inquiétude après quoi le statut de
milliers de correspondants qui sillonne
les états unis sera incertain ici
sébastien desrosiers radio canada
morrell